[Music]
for Milton's Paradise Lost two bad boys
and fan fatale we are seduced by the
dark and dangerous why does the devil
have the best tunes have we sanitized
the good and made it vacuous can we
imagine a world where the good was
exciting dramatic and fun or danger and
denial somehow essential to being alive
let me introduce us because more fully
so we have Christopher Hamilton
Christopher is reader and philosophy at
King's College London where he teaches
philosophy literature and film he
specializes in the work of Kierkegaard
and Nietzsche John Milbank is a
theologian and founder of the radical
orthodoxy movement his books include the
monstrosity of Christ co-authored with
Slava GTECH and his most recent book is
the politics of virtue and last but not
least
Patricia McCormack is professor of
continental philosophy at Anglia Ruskin
her books include sinner sexuality the
animal catalyst post human ethics and
most recently eco stafa chol aesthetics
so let's start with our first question
have we turned the idea of goodness into
something empty and lifeless I'm Chris I
think we'll turn to you for the first
thing I would say with respect to
thinking about good and evil and our
view of them is that it seems to me
perfectly manifest that human beings
have a nature and it's that they're part
of their nature is to be aggressive if
you imagined coming to a planet with a
species like ours and you've never been
to that planet before and you just
watched how people have those creatures
behaved and the history and you saw
human history which as the great German
philosopher Hegel said was is a
slaughter bench I think what you would
see is that it is essentially that it's
one blood bath after another this isn't
a deny of course that there are good
things that human beings have done some
of them
absolutely magnificent not morally
speaking and in the arts and so on but
it seems to me completely clear that the
explanation for human history being as
it is is indeed that human beings are by
nature aggressive creatures
we're also highly intelligent that's to
say we're very very good at survival but
pretty much bad at everything else
including controlling ourselves and we
are of course we have used our
intelligence to outstrip by a long way
our instinct or capacities to restrain
ourselves we in other words to put it
more simply we have weapons with which
we can kill each other
so one aspect of I think the problem
that we have been thinking about good is
that we do have a very primal
fascination towards violence and
aggression and I think we're largely in
denial about that I think that
particularly in modernity in the modern
West we like to think we have in the
Scent in the term of use for the debate
sanitized our understanding of the good
so that's the first point I make the
second point I will make is that if we
are thinking about the notion of the
good and we're thinking about that
particularly of course in a moral
context I take it in this debate because
of course there are plenty of things
that might be good that we can fully
accept I mean questions of you know
exciting ways of life but they might be
morally suspect so if we're restricting
ourselves to the idea of the morally
good then it seems to me the other thing
we have to bear in mind is that we have
a deeply fragmented notion of what that
is we have that fragmented notion for
variety reasons one is the that we are
the inheritors in particular of of
course Greek but also Christian
judeo-christian culture which themselves
are highly complex in their view of the
good but we can put that very very
simply by saying that we have notions of
the morally good which are in conflict
with each other I mean take classically
the relationship say between mercy and
justice we know that we can see these in
particular cases as being morally good
it can be morally good to forgive 2x
sighs merci and so on but we can also
see that in some way that that is in
conflict with the notion of justice with
what somebody deserves as a result of
what he or she has done so one problem
we have I think also in thinking about
the the notion of the good is this
fragmented aspect to it the third thing
that I think is difficult is that we
have inherited particularly from
Christianity or at least some strands of
Christianity or perhaps more directly
from the life of Jesus an idea of the
good as being absolutely pure and that
seems to me in one way a wholly mistaken
idea in another way quite correct the
way in which I think it's mistaken is
that it seems to me that the to put it
in these terms the virtues and vices are
bound up with each other the best
example of this is love any kind of love
romantic love but love of friendship
also the love that people have for their
parents or their children and so on or
people the love that people have for a
country or maybe even for a vocation is
partly underwritten by deeply
egotistical drives you know the the
parents who were proud of their children
at the school pantomime these are my
kids and look at my kids how lovely they
are now I've sometimes said this to
audiences who then think I'm being
cynical I'm not being cynical at all I
think it's perfectly normal I think it's
perfectly natural that we have this
egotistical attachment to those who are
close to us who are dear to us but it is
nonetheless an egotistical attachment
it's about me and about my life and what
revolves around me and it seems to me
that we are badly in denial about that
because we conceptualize the good as
being pure we have the idea that you
could be wholly virtuous without any
kind of as it were the vices
underwriting the virtues and it seems to
me that philosophers such as Nietzsche
are quite right which is that they if
you were to read the human soul of the
vices you would read it at the same time
of the virtues and the way very
dishonest about that
however so at one level I think the idea
of the good is absolutely pure is
mistaken on the other hand I think there
is something in the idea but and it is
an idea we do occasionally in our lives
very rarely or looking at the lives of
other people get a sense of the
possibility of a kind of life which is
absolutely lived in pure goodness a kind
of purity in a way a certain kind of
innocence but not an innocence that
doesn't know about the ways of the world
and but in my view is and my view is
that in the Western tradition we have
attached that notion very very strongly
to the life of Jesus which probably in
certain ways does express that for
example in his willingness to go on to
go to the cross but that is not a form
of goodness connect that can actually be
embodied in human life indeed I agree
with the German philosopher Hannah
addend that that kind of goodness is
destructive of the political realm and
destructive of human plurality so that
we have an intimation of a certain kind
of moral goodness the but it cannot be
embodied in our lives
thanks over to you John do you think
we've sanitized the good yeah absolutely
and I think we're profoundly under the
delusion that the good is boring I think
a lot of reasons for that is we think of
the good as something primarily that we
have to do but of course everything that
fully exists it is good like today and
how and why and the whole area and the
goodness is first experienced in that
way I think as a gift and the second
thing is we think of goodness in terms
of rules and the habitual and the
predictable that we should by now have
learned from laundry bags on that is
exactly the opposite way around that
everything merely identically repeated a
merely habitual is in fact bad is in
fact evil the real good is always
original always surprising always apt to
the arising situation otherwise it just
isn't good at all so we have a
completely false idea about the good I
think the other thing is that in in our
life too
where we're no longer mainly
agricultural laborers or craftsmen we
need endless titillation and diversion
so we've forgotten the fundamental good
of absorption its absorption that really
makes us happy absorption in agriculture
and gardening in crafts in dancing in
friendship in sex you know dancing like
at this this festival in music those are
the things that really make us happy and
there's very little amounts of kind of
absorption going on in the modern world
is very little absorption on offer it's
interesting that you can much more read
a poem again and again or listen to a
symphony again and again then you can
kind of watch a film again again and
again or even read a novel or even
Shakespeare again and again music which
is kind of nearer to sort of peace and
good is more something I think that you
can do again and again I think that the
further illusion that we're we're under
is a failure to read some pool properly
who'd already said everything that Nitra
said only infinitely more radically
because Paul saw the the link between
law and transgression so we only think
the game of transgression is fun because
we're always affirming the law and we
shouldn't be affirming the law because
okay we need the law we need laws but
they're merely reactive against they're
trying to contain an already existing
threat this isn't the original creative
good this is charity that Paul is trying
to get us back to so the game of law and
transgression that binary gets is
exactly something that we need to escape
so all the apparently you know
transgressive hero heroes and heroines
are far too conservative you know that
that that's the obviously I think you
know the real problem but then one could
say okay so we do we need to be sort of
hippies and Buddhists do we need to just
sort of make love and not war to be need
to get on totally with absorption well
actually no that would be premise
because we don't quite know the key to
that there really is injustice and evil
in the world where mysteriously
dominated by that and we have to fight
that and that's more if you like our
Western classical and Christian legacy
you know summed up really in the word
chivalry so so that we're right to be
excited by the counterplot we should be
suspicious about mere excitement of
plots but we should embrace the fact
that we find the counter plot of
fighting against evil exciting so I
don't know quite how to sort this out on
the one hand there's absorption on the
other hand there's the real adventure
that you should be excited about and
fighting evil because we're not yet back
in paradise where we'll be one day but
not yet and so for now that sense of the
adventure of fighting evil is oddly um
an important clue to the eschatological
absorption that we haven't yet achieved
and Patricia have we made good life list
have we emptied it out my preliminary
response to that question would be good
for whom and this leads to a much larger
a double bind I think and the first part
of the double bond is that good and evil
have been unnecessarily bifurcated
because what is good for one is not good
for another and what is considered evil
for one is not considered evil for
another and so one person's fallen angel
and rebel is another person's hero but
more importantly than that is the shift
or the tendency to go from a social
ordering and a very human signifying
system that arbitrarily distributes good
and evil based on what benefits those in
power more than what benefits the
oppressed to a situation of from
morality to ethics where it's more about
a very divided relationship between any
instant and any interaction any
interrelation allottee considering that
we all do exist in an assemblage in a
mesh of relations that our actions will
always have unpredictable effects on
others
so the question is not so much
evaluating overarching paradigms of is
this behavior good is this behavior evil
but both as a practice but also as an
evaluative occupation rather saying is
this situation am I expressing
intensities that will open up the
liberty of the other are my effects
going to be imposing power as a form of
oppression or are my actions going to be
commingling with the other to create a
feeling of joy and joy is again it's not
qualified it's not happiness but it is
an openness to further metamorphosis
further development rather than an
oppression so for me I think the moral
question is very different to the
ethical actualization and I also think
that the semi subjectivity of the
concept of good and evil is something
that masquerades behind this larger
human question where humans are all
perceived to be a certain kind of human
and perceived to have certain kind of
interests that are not logical not
natural but largely judiciary and
self-serving thanks Patricia different
ideas of what goodness is and how we
need to change our ways of thinking
about it
maybe you should turn to think about
evil so our first theme is why are we
doing two things which are dark and
dangerous crystallizes well it was I
said earlier I mean I think that um I
mean in a word the answer is that is
exciting that's not to say of course I
mean that doesn't have any particular
implication that that which is good is
not exciting I think it can be and I'm
I'm in agreement with much of what John
said about the idea of absorption of a
certain kind of mindfulness or as a form
of goodness but I think it's I think
that human beings are naturally
attracted to that which is exciting and
they are so because they're creatures
who had profoundly distracted distracted
from themselves was TS Eliot has it
distracted from distraction by
distraction and I think I think human
beings are profoundly distracted
Restless uneasy creatures
which is like pretty much everything in
human life has both a positive and a
negative side the positive side is that
it's the thing that keeps us driving
forward it's the thing that keeps us
imaginative and inventive but it's also
the thing that can get easily out of
control and I think that evil and
violence has a attaches itself readily
to that part of of the human soul that
restless side that that seeks excitement
and engagement and seeks loss of self
and in losing ourselves you know there's
a great line from Samuel Johnson the
eighteenth century man of letters who
says he who makes a beast of himself
forgets the pain of being a man
obviously that's put very much in terms
of 18th century English but it's the
idea that being a human being is a
tremendous burden it's a burden to think
about who one is it's a burden to live
with this kind of chattering mind that's
constantly distracted and the idea of
violence or the idea of evil the the
excitement of these things is precisely
the sense of as it were an emptying of
the self in a in a way that releases one
from oneself and this is this is one
reason why the great Jewish almost
Catholic thinker C Mon Vey is not
terribly well known in this country that
she died here in 1943 said that in there
were two limits to the will one limit is
just material objects I just can't go
through them they just stop my will the
other is human beings but human beings
limit my will not because of what they
are physically after all you might be
much physically weaker than I am and I
could just push you over if I wanted to
it's rather than something about you she
would say as sacred there may be other
ways of capturing that thought but
there's something about you that limits
my will but in those moments of
aggression or violence we see this
particularly in war that that evil and
the it becomes exciting because suddenly
that limit is no longer there
and I'm released into being able to do
what I want to do and so it seems to me
that evil aggression violence these have
a an intoxicating quality because of the
kinds of creatures that we are and again
I think we're dishonest with ourselves
about that because I don't think as much
we can do about it unless we were
actually honest about where this comes
from in the in the human soul thanks
John I wonder whether you want to join
in here would you agree with this
characterization of us you know I I
think I think I'd agree up to a point
and I think you would probably sort of
also agree that that the trouble with
that you this kind of an intoxication
you know the danger of evil is that is
that it it does seem superficially
attractive but tends to Paul after a
while it becomes in fact after a while
simply boring yeah and and kind of
routinized and I think there's also the
question of sort of suddenly there are
no limits but you know if there are
genuinely no limits
you know why is it this game of
transgression this it this is why I'm
wanting to raise this issue about the
you know the secret complicity with law
but I do think there's another dimension
to this that I haven't mentioned so far
you know why why are we attracted by
kind of outlaws and pirates and Robin
Hood and and and and so forth and and
you know we have the phrase honor
amongst thieves and I think this is
because really and truly sometimes it in
in a very kind of rigid impersonal kind
of habit bound culture where there is a
real suppression of certain human
qualities they they then exist sort of
more in in these exits you know they the
idea presumably this is behind some
phenomena like terrorism and so on that
you're you know there's this sense of
kind of unlimited Brotherhood and and so
in that sense it's almost a sense of a
kind of trapped virtue and we need to
understand why that that can be
attractive any it can you know just to
condemn
is wrong we need to realize it is
witness to something missing item in our
usual understanding of what of what what
is life and we need to we need more
absorption both with things and and and
and with other people I think may I
throw my a very briefly just to say I
agree entirely with that and I think one
way of putting it is it's the way that
kid or adult or door know their 20th
century German philosophy we live we
live in the administered Society yeah
and so what becomes attractive is the
idea of living out as it were on the
other side of the the margin so that we
we constantly tell ourselves we're
satisfied living in this highly
bourgeois regulated ordered administered
world but in fact we know deep down that
there are dean forces of the self that
aren't aren't being responded to and I
think the other thing is the thing about
the boringness of evil WH Auden has a
marvelous passage in one of his essays
where he says those who are in hell know
they're in hell and they know the gates
of Hell are opened but they're
frightened of walking out because
walking out would involve a change of
their life they'd have to admit their
own mistake but they actually they
really want to go out and that sense
that there's a kind of boringness about
the repetitive I think is absolutely
right and again we don't we don't I mean
it's one reason I think in fact that
there's no people are generally in
agreement that for example fascist Nazi
fascism couldn't produce any great art
because there's something so sterile
about that world in is evil but it's a
bit like the Mafia the way it offers
another kind of another kind of order
and the more its sinister but it's much
more interpersonal ISM is evil
inherently boring well I think that for
many people who talk about good and evil
and about transgression and about this
whole idea of repetition and boredom
it's because they've always had access
to the most privileged positions of
power and they have never had to be
demonized or fight against what they
consider inherently good that is not
really good for the planet and is not
really good for everyone but is
primarily good for a very very niche
form of the human
and so I think all of these grand
narratives about selfhood and personhood
and humankind struggles against tedium
and you know conflict that many people
haven't had the luxury I think there's a
sense of luxuriating in one's own power
that is a little privileged and kind of
nauseating because for many people and
many you know sort of movements that
have been demonized they have been
demonized because of their disobedience
not because they seek to be able but
being designated as evil is because they
are disobedient but they are also
necessary so some of the movements that
we now consider great and wonderful were
initially designated as evil and yet we
would today call them beneficial and
good and so I think that we need to take
a great deal of care in talking about
personhood human subjectivity and what
we mean by good and evil as a poly vocal
collective of very different individuals
rather than speaking from a neutral
position that I think is mythological
and self-serving thank you I mean this
brings us back to our second theme which
is again there's this topic of the good
and whether we need to rethink what
goodness is if we're able to move
forwards I mean maybe done you can
earlier invoking us lately sort of spin
Assisting delusion picture and and some
of that I would want to go along with
actually that the you know the the sense
of it is a matter of absorbing what what
is positive you know that building up
your your real being and strength for
not being sucked down by what Spinoza
called beside passions but but I think
that in the end you can only do that
with harmony with other human beings and
indeed with all the other creatures on
the planet and I I think there's a
there's a sense that at least some of
what Spinoza is saying is important for
forgetting to a
or ontological sense of goodness the
less kind of moralistic sense of
goodness there is there is actually a
false one
sorry mistaken in thinking that being
good is being disciplined think it is
about having restrictions and keeping
within those well when no in in a sense
that the good is about having good
habits and the strange thing is that the
capacity to be original to repeat
differently and so on does require
discipline it requires you not simply to
be the victim of the passive that
Spinoza is talking about but to be able
actively to absorb our outside
influences so there's a strange alliance
between discipline and playing is you
know you can't play football properly
without discipline ironically you can't
be playful enough without discipline
Chris what was the question over a
father relation between goodness and
discipline well well okay I mean I think
it's completely clear that if we're
talking about moral goodness or ethical
good I mean one could distinguish these
and philosophers sometimes do but let's
not worry about that it seems to me that
discipline is inevitably part of that
for a perfectly good reason which is
that if I'm to respect another person
all I'm to respect the obligations I
have and they needn't be terribly ground
obligations they can just be the
obligations as I have for example to
turn off at the time agreed to do my
teaching at college or the obligation to
mark my students essays and so on and so
forth that that requires discipline that
requires me to hold in check something I
might want to do otherwise you know I
might not simply want to mark those
essays but I've agreed to do it and
that's what I do so I think I think from
that point of view morality
unquestionably involves the notion of
discipline it involves the notion of the
limits of the will as I said earlier in
the vaults these notions of obligation
and and very old-fashioned notion but
the notion of duty which I think he is
there but it doesn't follow from that of
course as I intimated earlier that all
goodness is moral goodness far from it
and part of the problem is that we can
perfectly well think that there are
lives which are excellent that might be
morally suspect in various ways I mean
one of the facts it seems of human
existence for example is that most of
the grey creators of the greatest works
of art music literature and so on
they've been pretty shabby people and
often very unpleasant people and that's
a certain price that we're willing to
pay at least at times for the things
that they produce and it seems to me
that that's part of our difficulty our
difficulties that we can see certain
kinds of lives as excellent but at the
same time morally suspect and I my own
view is that we live in an age in which
we are too ready to suppose them
he must triumph of those other forms of
excellence I mean this guy this is a
problem that goes right back to
Aristotle
because in Aristotle's ethics there's
the question about the virtuous life but
in fact the word that we translate you
from the Greek as virtuous is just in
fact excellent
and then when what Aristotle says is
this what's the excellent life for a
human being and it turns out that it's
not quite the same as anything that we
in modernity as inheritors of
Christianity would think so part of the
problem is a tremendous complexity in
our notion of what counts as a good life
and we can be torn between the morally
good and and good in or and excellent in
various other ways I mean who gets to
decide what good is is it connected with
power in some way well in in part of
course it's connected with power but
it's not only connected with power if
you thought that it were connected only
with power then it would simply be
reduced to that then that would be a
very in my view and unhelpfully
reductive view I mean there's there's no
question that certain things as we said
earlier certain things have been demon
old movements have been demonized as as
evil and we've come later to think that
that's not the case but it's also the
case that they've been things that we've
demonized as evil and that they're
pretty sure I mean I mentioned the Nazi
fascism for example and I for one will
be willing to say that that was from
beginning to end an evil movement and I
don't think that's an expression of any
kind of I mean I'm not sure how far the
notion of neutrality goes in in
philosophy but I or in thinking about
life but I certainly don't think that
it's an expression of power I think it's
a recognition of what was there and the
reality but it's not I mean the question
who gets to decide is in is in a way too
simplistic it's rather that it's just
part of the conversation of humanity and
and and human beings or particular local
cultures in which they're trying to work
things out and it's not so much that any
one particular person decides these
things gradually emerge sometimes for
the better sometimes for the worse
sometimes we make gargantuan errors and
mistakes sometimes we get things more or
less right and with hindsight we can see
that but there's it's not really it's
much much more complex than the
relations of power those of course
they're in there I think in some way
inevitably perhaps you think that
we see goodness is tangled up with
relations of power but do you think we
can think good outside those relations
well as I said earlier I think that good
is both retrospectively evaluated and
also imposed as a sort of ambition for
ethical openness so it sort of comes
down to a very anthropocentric
signifying system where things are
evaluated rather than kind of unthinking
unmaking opening up because III do you
know wonder about the use you know to be
done with the judgement of God as out so
I would say I think that we can look at
the ability of another to have the
manifestation of novelty in their
existence and we can say well I did
everything in my capacity to allow that
openness to exist or we can say I did
something that limited that capacity for
that other to experience novel
situations and novel encounters and you
know historically evil has also been
associated with novelty I think now evil
especially with the whole edge Lord
rubbish evil is associated with being a
bit edgy because people don't want to be
inclusive of diversity but I think that
ultimately when we talk about good and
evil we are talking about yes a complex
understanding of power but power isn't
an unseeded function so power as so I
think the question has to be when we
enunciate something as being good or
evil what is the purpose fullness of
that rather than what are we doing to
actively seek a good which sort of is a
different kind of thing because it's not
evaluative and it's not retrospective
it's hopeful and it's you know ambitious
in the face of impossibility and so I
think that even in that sense we're
looking at good being a theme that's
retrospective and good being a hoped-for
opening up
which you know may work out badly but we
won't not when you mention this idea of
when to think about good non
anthropocentric Li what what does that
mean I mean if we think about morality
as a kind of structure that humans have
imposed so I would I would I would pick
up from Michelle says use of grace I
think that some the the the human
devastation of the world would be well
to stop aligning good with action and
bad with passivity or apathy and I think
that you know binary thinking in general
is problematic but grace is lovely
because it is the goodness in stepping
aside and in modern forms of activism
goodness can often come as active
boycott but historically goodness has
come through a sense of hoped for grace
where we simply allow the other to be
without demanding knowledge of the other
without demanding the other come up to
our anthropocentric level of equivalence
so for me maybe there is a deep
unknowability in good that is attractive
because it's difficult but also demands
a very artistic perception of practice
and so in that sense I think it's very
sexy because it's mystical you know it
verges on mystical so yeah thank you I
mean that conveniently brings us to our
final theme which is what can we do to
make good more exciting and sexy as you
said well if anyone stood in front of
Bernini st. Teresa they know that good
can be more sexy but I think imagination
and artistic practices of activism and
really trying to not impose judgment
before the fact is both ethically open
and possibly a way of understanding good
as novel and unknowable so not
prescriptive yeah rather than you know
because really when you think about it I
think that the the the concept of
violence is tedious because it's
repetitive is because it was once
unknown and unknowable but now we know
it to exhaustion so it's become boring
so this you know this cessation of
is very important or this you know
cultivation of difference within
repetition is very important and so a
celebration of mystic unknowability I
think it converges good innate what say
it converges light and dark it's seeing
in the dark and it's being blinded by
light rather than good and evil as being
this prescriptive preformed because
ultimately we can only reflect on things
being good and evil and we have to just
hope that we are seeking quite a bit
about his right and fits with what I've
already said about about being good
being absorbed shown being about habits
of non-identical repetition and more a
matter of trying to inculcate virtues
which which are at once you know
generalizable roles and yet always
incredibly particular I mean I think the
difficulty comes you know when you talk
simply about sort of opening up and
giving up space and so on that whether
we're talking about amongst people or
amongst those other agents there were
animals and plants and so on the
question is you know how do we all fit
in together how do we you know share
that share this planet how are we going
to interact and about point it it seemed
absolutely the language of grace is
right but you know if it's not merely a
kind of Protestant imputed grace if it's
a kind of more limped on grace you know
informing our lives there then itself
seem to have an aesthetic aspects which
I think can get onto you your terrain
and I think it's interesting that it's
very difficult in the end to sort of
separate the good in the aesthetic
that's why philosophers like Charles
Braves have talked so much in aesthetic
terms about goodness and and similarly
you know when we think about works about
you know the invocation the way they
provoke you knows you know good peaceful
desires and so on and yet at the same
time I think you've got you can't make
that too easy you know and those we're
not the less yet the perfect unity or of
obvious
setec and the good you know the perfect
convertibility of the transcendentals as
scholastics would have understood it and
David Bentley Hart has a very very good
essay or on all this you know about the
fascination and wickedness and I I
really hesitate to speak about this with
Stanley Stanley fish sitting in front of
me but but nonetheless you know why is
Milton Satan attractive wise Don Juan
attractive and and there's a certain
sense here that we you know we cannot
deny a certain vibe aesthetic vitality
you know even though it's as if we're
trapped and it sort of tells us maybe
that there's something we need that we
haven't fully integrated yet you know
and I'm well you know I wouldn't want to
go too far down your road about the
romantic artist I think we need to ask
how far there is to some degree a kind
of modern phenomena but at the same time
you know as a child Peggy says you know
it's very few people who manage to be
both great makers and philosophers and
great actors and we need to get away
from the idea of you know a morality
that everybody needs to do everything
all that the same good is is good for
some people there are some daring things
that are good for some people to do and
very bad for other people to do that's a
perfectly sound moral judgment and you
know the fact that some people have to
focus on making and so on is something
that we we have to understand and you
know there are sort of rival
deficiencies and and in a sense all that
needs integrating at a much more social
level and I think our problem is that
because we we just pursue kind of money
and you know formal rules or kind of a
we despair of harmonizing differences
that none of this works in in the way
our society is set up at the moment so
we shouldn't think about good
universally we have to think about it on
an individual level well know both
things are true because because yeah the
more you think
the good in a platonic way and something
transcendence the more you the less you
think of it in this boring modern
Kantian way as being about a set of
merely fixed rules the more you
understand that it can vary in
individuals and that you know the point
about being good as kikou says in a
sense it is becoming subjective but but
but but he also relates that very
powerfully to social roles like marriage
for it for it for examples so that you
you're doing that in an interrelation
'el way but it's kind of shockingly non
bland and non moralistic compared to the
way that we're usually thinking about it
I think well well I think we even trying
well should we even try or let's think
about whether I mean I think the writ I
mean one of the things that John is
saying there with which I agree is a
distinction between let's say morality
and moralism and one of the things one
of the things I think that's
characteristic of the modern age is and
it's a point actually the nature makes
which is with the decline of and the
decline of religious faith or the
decline of established religions
morality steps in to fill the gaps so in
my view part of the problem we have in
thinking about the interestingness that
if that's the right way to put it of a
good is that we have a moralized
conception of morality and we would do
well to rid ourselves of that and some
of the things I think that John has been
saying about the varieties of goodness
including the varieties of moral
goodness in individuals is something
that we would do well to think about I
think the other aspect of it and it's
something I've not mentioned but I think
it's tremendously important is that we
overlook in general in our lives how
exposed they are too radical contingency
to the fact that so much of what happens
to us is just chance fluke good and bad
luck and one aspect of that is the fact
that we are born here
talking about the people here in this
audience and of course myself we're born
in a world which is a world largely of
Plenty and my view is that a great deal
of the things that all the great deal of
our moral goodness that were a great
deal of our sense that we are morally
good or morally better than people in
the past doesn't come from a genuine
feature of what we are or a soul or
ourself but comes rather from the fact
that we are held in place by a
particular kind of social world which
makes a certain kind of thing possible
for us a certain kind of way of living
to put it in the crudest terms if I got
nothing and you've got a lot I've got a
real incentive to take from you because
I've not I've got nothing to lose in the
first place
if however we live in a world of Plenty
where there's a certain kind of
equilibrium of goods then of course that
we have less though it's there's less
investment in aggressing against each
other and of course one of the things
that we've done unfortunately is to
export that conflict here which exists
much less between us for example in this
audience export this to a distinction
between north and south so that a great
deal of our problems our economic and
social problems are exported essentially
in the form of problems about climate
and food supply and so on to more
impoverished nations so this seems to me
an extremely important thing to think
about when we're thinking about good and
how interesting it is it's the way in
which we shouldn't overestimate our own
capacities the way in which we should
see how we're held in place and this
seems to me a line of a line of thought
that comes particularly strongly through
Hannah Arendt's work on the banality of
evil you know the famous case of
Eichmann who was one of the out of Ajman
was one of the architects of the
deportation of the Jews to the camps in
the east and was put on try and
eventually in in Jerusalem and he was
what she called a desk murderer because
he simply signed pieces of paper to
organize the transportation of the Jews
not thinking about what he was actually
- there this actually meant you know
millions of deaths and her point was in
talking about the banality of evil is
that in another epoch he would have just
had been a bureaucrat perhaps he would
have been me doing
bureaucratic things at the University
filling in the reforms applying for you
know grant and whatever it might be heat
marking essays and the consequence of
that is that the radical contingency of
the goodness that we have that each of
us have is it's not a thing as it were
that's my possession it is in a way and
I think in the kind of vocabulary that
John would use it is in a way a kind of
gift it's chance and we should remember
that because otherwise we become
complacent about our own capacities and
about what could happen tomorrow if
suddenly there were no food or no water
or or whatever we have a lot of time
thank you so much for coming please join
me in thanking our speaker in the
debates talks and interviews subscribe
today to the Institute of Arts and ideas
at IAI TV
you